the implications of god are in the
hierarchy of things including
us and in the imperfection even of the
highest things that we see
[Music]
why would a place devoted to learning
the exercise of the mind to rational
understanding
also be interested in faith aren't they
contradictory
and that i will address at a little bit
of length because that would be why we
study genesis here
philosophy is the love of wisdom
and wisdom is an achievement of the
intellect of what you can know by
thinking things through
we kind of start with the things in
front of us
and try to understand how we know what
they are
same thing one of the things in front of
us is each other ourselves
what are we and so you start with
questions the credit philosophy begins
this way with
what are we how should we live what are
these other things we see and how do we
know what they are
how do we figure it out and there's a
great account of that
in classic philosophy and classical
philosophy of course was born
in a time before the christian phase in
pagan times
400 or so years before christ
and their account runs like this they
say well you know when you
start thinking about how you recognize
things you're asking the question how do
you use common nouns
[Music]
um down there there's a glass which they
put here for me in case i get raspy
and i'll hold it up so you can see it
right
and if you think about it that's one
glass it's a kind there are many kinds
many many kinds
and somehow we always recognize them and
the fact that we can use the common noun
glass
is the central operation according to
the classics of human reason it's the
thing we can do that the other creatures
can't do
and yet when we realize that about
ourselves and look inside ourselves we
see that whatever it is about us that
makes us different
that thing too is imperfect first of all
it's located in a perishable body and
second of all
we have this uh thing that is about us
about the way we learn and the way we
think
it's the reason why students get dark
circles under their eyes
at finals time we go from one thing to
the next thing to the next thing and we
have to piece them together while we go
we don't know everything at once we
can't really see
anything except what we can see
aristotle says there's
nothing in the soul that doesn't get
there through the census
so that's a kind of a limit well once
you see what those problems are
you can imagine a being that knows
everything in an instant sees everything
in an instant
the implications of god are in the
hierarchy of things including
us and in the imperfection even of the
highest things that we see
and that means that the humanities raise
the question
of god and so you need to be thinking
about that
but then think about this how are you
going to know about god
because if you imagine a perfect being
it would be omnipotent that means it
could do anything
and then on the other hand to be
omnipotent it would need to be
omniscient it would mean to know
everything
and if it was the origin of things it
would be the
creator now i will tell you that in
greek philosophy
they don't imagine a creator because
they stick with what they see and they
see that the planets are always there
and they always move in the patterns
they move and
grown-up dogs give rise to baby dogs and
acorns produce
oak trees and so the implication is that
it's gone on forever
but on the other hand they did ask the
question you know
did all this start somewhere
and if so where and if there actually
was a creator
then he would actually have to be
outside nature
he wouldn't be just that dense lump at
the beginning of things
he'd have to be something outside that
thing to be the source of it
and he would need to be an eternal thing
a thing that didn't start in order to be
perfect
i'm saying and so then you start drawing
a picture of god
and that picture is supported
by the traditions of learning
that come to us especially through
judaism and christianity
uh in christianity jesus is the word
that's what god has to say just like we
say use words and only we use them
and so there's an invitation in the
faith to think
and try to explain understanding that
we're unlikely to be able to explain
everything at once including especially
the thing
of which we could have no sensory
evidence the creator of everything
and that's why in the tradition
the study of god theology has always
been part of the canon of the liberal
arts
and fits in the canon understanding that
it's
the faithful part of it the revealed
part of it
that that part is a different kind of
knowing
than the kind that we undertake when we
observe
and think and record and calculate
and then the natural sciences experiment
and it doesn't mean that they're not
both valuable but they are different
and so to call yourself a holy
thoughtful people as far as a human
being could be a person
holy thoughtful person
you'd have to do some thinking about god
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and
invite you to explore all of hillsdale
college's online courses
they are free and for everyone who loves
to learn